[Music]
foreign
[Music]
did you know that Netflix doesn't not
offer traditional health insurance to
their employees instead Netflix offers a
15 000 yearly allowance if you want you
can use this with one of Netflix's
Kaiser or Collective health plans but
you can also use the allowance with any
provider you want and if you end up
spending less than fifteen thousand
dollars on health insurance you can even
get up to five thousand dollars back and
it's not just your health insurance
benefit that you can get in cash either
you can actually get all of your
benefits in the form of cash even
including your stock compensation this
approach has resulted in Netflix paying
the highest cash salaries in the world
period basically imagine Google tier
compensation but all in the form of cash
that's Netflix combine this with the
fact that Netflix tries to provide each
employee with 100 percentile salaries
and that things get crazy real fast take
software Engineers for example the
highest paid software engineer at
Netflix who has submitted their salary
levels is a back-end engineer located in
Chicago earning 1.5 million dollars per
year if you take a closer look you'll
see that the salary consists of 1.5
million in cash zero in stock and zero
in bonus Google does have similarly paid
Engineers as well the highest paid
engineer at Google comes in at 1.27
million dollars per year but if you take
a closer look you'll see that only 340
000 of that is in cash 794 000 is in the
form of stock and 139 000 is in the form
of a bonus and this is not just the case
with software Engineers either whether
you're a technical program manager a
product manager or even the CEO your
compensation can be taken entirely in
the form of cash last year Netflix's
co-ceo Ted sarandos for example received
a 20 million dollars in cash this makes
Netflix the highest cash pair in the
world period there may be some
exceptions here and there and that make
more than what Netflix offers but as an
organization no one have pays higher
cash salaries than Netflix this doesn't
mean that you're forced to take cash
though if you want to take stock you can
let HR know it and that they can convert
your entire compensation to stock the
founder of Netflix read Hastings for
example chose to take his 40 million
package mostly in stock most employees
however generally choose fully cash
compensations so here's on Netflix ended
up becoming the cash king and the pros
and cons of this practice
these crazy high-catch salaries are no
doubt unorthodox but that's just one of
the many practices on Netflix that are
unorthodox breed Hastings has an
extremely unique leadership style that's
centered around Freedom responsibility
and transparency he likes to be brutally
honest and isn't afraid to say things
how they are for example you often hear
CEOs refer to their employees as being a
family but really knows that that's not
true there is only one reason you're
there for money hopefully you actually
somewhat like the work and what the
company is trying to accomplish but
those are just pluses the bottom line is
that you're there for money and the
company has you there so that they can
make more money that's it read is super
candid about this and is straightforward
in saying that Netflix is a team not a
family and all of his company's policies
are based around this reality not
forcing stock compensation or health
insurance onto employees is part of this
approach as a CEO and it's natural to
think that your stock is the best but
Reed understands that not all of his
employees would agree so he doesn't
force it similarly he doesn't pay
employees based on how hard they work or
how much time they spend in the office
in fact Netflix has no 9 to 5 policy or
even a vacation policy instead it
employees are given a task expectations
and the deadline if you're able to
perform to these standards while working
10 hours a week good for you on the
other hand even if you're working 100
hours per week but you don't even get
close to what's expected they're gonna
look for someone else that's that simple
given this philosophy it makes sense why
Netflix gives their employees so much
control over their compensation but just
having this philosophy isn't enough to
utilize the strategy the second thing to
note is that Netflix is actually in a
position where they can afford it just
because you're a big company does not
mean that you can afford it Amazon for
example has extraordinarily low profit
margins so amaz Amazon could not even
dream of paying these cash salaries but
thanks to Netflix's extremely lucrative
subscription model Netflix can actually
afford it there is also a bit of
strategy to this as well one of the
reasons that companies hand out stock
compensation is because they're hoping
that employees will hang on to it and
that it'll motivate them but the reality
is that a substantial number of
employees liquidate their stock as soon
as they receive it even Tim Cook did
this despite literally it being CEO Reed
approached this from a practical
perspective and figured why dilute my
company and hand it out to people that
don't even want it especially when I can
just afford to pay them in cash really
this line of reasoning makes a lot of
sense and it's surprising that other
cash Rich companies don't do the same
foreign
so that's why Netflix offers their
compensations in cash but is there
actually any real benefit to this well
absolutely for one employees don't have
to deal with stock fluctuations here's
the thing the stock compensation figures
that you see on salary websites aren't
constant figures let's take a Facebook
director for example according to levels
a Facebook director earns 881 000 per
year in stock however this compensation
figure only comes to fruition if the
stock price stays constant throughout
the job in other words Facebook will not
provide you with more shares of stock
just because the share price Falls
instead a set number of shares are
determined when you get hired usually
these stock plans are set up to last
four years from the day you get hired so
if you get hired as a Facebook director
you wouldn't be offered 881 000 per year
rather you'd be offered 3.5 million
dollars for the next four years at
antichran share prices from there you'll
get access to a portion of this talk
every year this might not sound like a
big difference but it definitely can be
for example imagine that you were hired
at Facebook in September of 2021 since
then Facebook stock has plummeted it 70
which would mean that your 881 000 worth
of stock is only worth 264 000 by the
time you get it now of course that still
adds up to a total compensation of seven
hundred thousand dollars but that's
almost half of a 1.3 million despite the
fact that you're doing the same job now
imagine that this same scenario took
place in Netflix Netflix stock has also
crashed as much as 75 since their Peak
last year but if you're a Netflix
director earning 1.3 million dollars
last year you'd still be earning the
full 1.3 million as long as you didn't
get laid off of course a similar
argument could be made for the health
insurance credit as well usually a
substantial number of employees don't
even use the company provided health
insurance because they're covered by the
your spouse's company or their parents
company or whatever the case may be this
is awesome for companies given that they
can boast about having great insurance
plans while not even having to pay for a
bunch of their employees on the flip
side this sucks for employees given that
health insurance is technically a part
of the total compensation but they're
not actually receiving it Netflix's
health insurance credit however would
ensure that employees aren't fully left
out while employees that won't be able
to leverage the full fifteen thousand
dollars without getting a health
insurance plan they can at least get
five thousand dollars in cash so in the
end Netflix is Cash compensation it not
only ensures that employees get a stable
income but also that they're able to
make the most of all their perks
foreign
cached compensations have a lot of perks
like anything they also come with a fair
number of cons as well for example while
cash salaries may seem nice during
recessionary periods during bull markets
it's the exact opposite let's go back to
the Facebook director instead of
assuming that you joined in 2021 what if
we assumed that you joined in 2017
between 2017 and 2021 Facebook stock
grew by over 100 percent this means that
if you joined Facebook in 2017 your
stock compensation would have grown to
over 1.7 million dollars in 2021 despite
the fact that you're doing the same job
this in turn would increase your total
compensation from 1.3 million to 2.2
million meanwhile the Netflix director
who joined in 2017 it would still be
making 1.3 million now Netflix is pretty
good at increasing salaries according to
market conditions but they definitely
wouldn't be able to match rise to 2.2
million because the market rate didn't
actually increase that much Facebook
actually only paid 1.3 million you
simply ended up earning 2.2 million
because the stock prices worked in your
favor best case scenario the market rate
may have increased to 1.4 or 1.5 million
and that that's what Netflix would be
able to match so by taking your entire
salary and cash you give up the
opportunity for exponential growth so
work in your favor granted you will also
eliminate the risk of it working against
you but when we're talking about a
company like Netflix we're talking about
giving up Market leading returns one way
to work around this would be to Simply
invest your salary yourself or request
for a portion of your salary to be given
in stock but you wouldn't be able to buy
nearly as much stock as Facebook or
Google offered you due to the second
shortfall of cash salaries which is high
taxes when you're earning seven figures
in cash you can bet that the government
is going to tax the hell out of you if
you're in California it's probably going
to be over 50 percent meanwhile if you
had a lot of stock compensation you'd
still be paying a massive tax tax bill
but maybe you could reduce the
percentage to something closer to forty
percent and when we're talking about
seven figure salaries that's an extra
six figures that you get to keep
something else to note is that the
unlimited vacation time is also not as
good as it may seem at first glance you
see it employees generally feel bad when
you take time off in an unlimited PTO
environment and on average they actually
end up taking too fewer days off per
year so Netflix ends up coming off as
the nice employer that offers unlimited
time off even though that doesn't
actually translate to more time being
taken off also most companies have a
policy of paying out accrued PTO when
you leave the company under good terms
for companies with unlimited PTO though
there is no accrued PTO so they can
avoid paying that so while such policies
do have their perks they're by no means
perfect either
foreign
Netflix has taken an approached a
compensation that's extremely uncommon
not only do they pay fat Tech salaries
but they paid all in cash this is
largely due to their philosophy and
extraordinary profitability while there
are advantages and the disadvantages to
this compensation structure I very much
think that it's a step in the right
direction giving employees more control
of how they get paid is never a bad
thing now of course with no structured
health insurance plans or retirement
plans there's gonna be some Bozo who
spent all the cash and has no money left
when they have a health emergency or are
approaching retirement but for the rest
of us who are relatively sensible and
take ownership of our financial
situation I think this is awesome and I
would be a fan of the system being
implemented much more frequently but
that's just what I think would you
prefer an all-cash compensation comment
that down below also drop a like if you
finally understand where all of your
Netflix payments are going and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community such as activity ideas and it
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one